one of the things that I'll be honest
with you surprised me when I did your
show in person afterwards I said mate
now that we're good mates how about you
on block me on Twitter yeah and you went
oh I've blocked you on Twitter and I
went yeah I made I took the piss out of
you overcovered and that's when you
surprised me because you went yeah I
deserved it yeah I did not expect that
actually given your public personas I've
changed my mind on a few things with
kovid because the science changed so
I'll give you an example and I'm quite
happy to admit this and talk about it
and people was like ah there you go yeah
because to me it changed so I'll give
you a classic example uh when they said
that vaccines couldn't transmit the
virus I said okay right in that case
anyone who doesn't have the vaccine
right now represents a clear and present
threat to spreading this virus and
killing people so you're selfish
bastards and I'm going to call you out
on that and by the way those who do have
the vaccine they should have more
freedoms because they're not going to
better transmit it once they've had the
jack